[Music]
the sea is filled with incredibly unique
life forms coming in a variety of shapes
sizes colors and appendages
many of such creatures are incredible
Predators who lurk in the far reaches of
the cold dark ocean
from the terror-inducing great white
shark to the insidiously clever killer
whale to the snapping jaws of the
powerful leopard seal to the
outrageously fast Marlin
creatures like this strike fear into the
hearts of many
but the biggest and scariest Predators
aren't necessarily the deadliest
for great white sharks only about 48 of
surface attacks on seals result in
successful kills
leopard seals only catch their fish prey
in 64 of their attempts
to find one of the most effective
Predators you need to set your sights on
something much smaller and in much
shallower Waters
residing in coastal regions around the
world is the oddly shaped sea creature
known as the seahorse
seahorses belong to the cignathid family
of fish which includes pipe fish and sea
dragons
there are about 50 seahorse species
ranging in size from 2 to 35 centimeters
each resembling a frankenstein-like
creation with bits and pieces taken from
various animals combined to make one
extraordinary fish
seahorses are one of the most effective
hunters in the sea with a success rate
of over 90 percent
that's two to three times higher than
other predatory fish and it's all thanks
to their unusual design
from their chameleon-like eyes that move
independently of one another allowing
them to view both what's in front of
them and behind them at the same time
to their monkey-like prehensile tales
that securely anchor them to objects to
their incredibly flexible and strong
body armor seahorses are built for
battle
but seahorses are strange and more than
just their appearance and they are
impressive even beyond their hunting
skills their adaptations for survival
are among the strangest in the animal
kingdom and seahorses however cute and
quirky are a survival Powerhouse of the
sea
foreign
horses and their relatives are the only
known vertebrate animals where pregnancy
and birth are performed by the males
while other animal dads May house and
protect fertilized eggs such as water
bugs Cardinal fish and many bird species
male seahorses do much more
after an elaborate courting dance a
mating pair of seahorses will entwine
their tails and line up the females egg
duct called the ovipositor with the
male's brood pouch opening
the female then deposits her eggs into
the pouch
scientists once believed the eggs were
fertilized inside the pouch through an
internal sperm duct
however dissections have disproved this
Theory with a study on the yellow
seahorse finding instead that the sperm
duct opening is located 4.5 millimeters
above the pouch opening
this means that the sperm travels
outside the male seahorse's body meeting
with the eggs as they are deposited into
The Brood pouch
videos of this event have found that the
Yellow Sea horses pouch stays open for
just six seconds
making them uniquely efficient at
fertilization since in this incredibly
small window they produce between a
hundred and a thousand embryos
and once inside The Brood pouch itself
becomes rather extraordinary functioning
similarly to a mammalian placenta by
providing oxygen and nutrients to the
growing sea horse embryos compared to
eggs that develop externally eggs that
are incubated internally come with
different challenges one in particular
is a means for Respiratory gas exchange
in order to survive embryos need a
constant exchange of respiratory gases
oxygen and carbon dioxide however being
in an enclosed space makes this
difficult
in mammals this exchange is accomplished
through the blood flow from the mother
to the placenta to the umbilical cord to
the fetus and Back Again
in seahorses scientists believe it
happens nearly the same way through
blood flow from the father to the
embryos and back
by Examining The Brood pouches of the
big belly seahorse researchers even
found that they remodel throughout
gestation to accommodate the growing
embryos after fertilization seahorse
embryos become embedded in the lining of
the brood pouch which contains numerous
blood vessels
as the embryos develop and require more
oxygen the lining becomes thinner and
more wrinkled providing the surface area
needed for even more blood vessels
as these changes to the brood pouch
mirror the growth of the seahorse
fetuses their findings indicate that the
pouch is acting in just the same way as
a placenta providing a means to exchange
oxygen and carbon dioxide and even
nutrients through blood flow
the whole gestational process of a male
seahorse takes anywhere between 10 days
to 6 weeks depending on the species
then through a series of muscle
contractions as many as a thousand fully
developed babies are shot from the pouch
into the sea
with these functions performed by the
females in nearly every other animal
scientists are left wondering why in
this case is it the males
some theorize that male pregnancy leads
to more seahorse babies since without
having to carry out the pregnancy the
females are free to start making more
eggs right after they deposit them in
the males and when only 0.5 percent of
seahorse Offspring survive to become
reproducing adults making a lot of
babies is crucial for the survival of
this one-of-a-kind fish
[Music]
when you're as small as a seahorse
protection from predators is another
survival necessity and here seahorses
once again evolved a unique solution for
most sea creatures hard rigid structures
such as scales shells and exoskeletons
act as an armor against predators
but seahorses took a different approach
with an armor that is instead highly
deformable and flexible
it consists of a series of bony plates
and as the seahorse moves the plates
slide over one another allowing for a
wider range of motion compared to fish
with scales
these plates aren't as hard as the armor
of other sea animals which means that
when they experience a force like a bite
from a large fish the plates deform
instead of fracture but it's the
orientation of the plates themselves
that allow the seahorse to survive most
attacks
unlike typical animal tails which are
cylindrical a seahorse tail has a square
cross section
to explore the benefits of a square tail
and how it compares to a traditional
cylindrical tail a group of researchers
made a 3D printed model of a seahorse
tail composed of 36 square segments each
with four L-shaped bony plates as well
as a similarly segmented cylindrical
tail
they found that while the cylindrical
tail became squished and damaged when
crushed the square tail flattened out
and deflected damage away from the
vertebral column inside allowing it to
absorb more energy before breaking
mechanical tests have found that under
compressive loads they can deform up to
50 percent without harming the vertebrae
inside
with this strength and flexibility
allowing for agile movement as well as
protection scientists are exploring its
potential use as flexible armor in
fracture resistant structures and in
robotics
scientists also determined that flat
sides provide more attachment points
when gripping onto objects which due to
their poor swimming ability is how
seahorses spend most of their time
their terrible swimming skills are a
result of their upright position as well
as their lack of pelvic fins and tail
fins their movement is limited to a
small dorsal fin on their back that
propels them forward and a pectoral fin
on either side of their head that steers
them where they want to go
these poor swimming skills make them one
of the slowest fish in the sea
it also explains their mostly sedentary
lifestyle clinging to seagrass or Coral
and while their upright stature may seem
disadvantageous it actually helps them
with their protection
like many animals seahorses evolved to
fit their environment and when their
ocean habitat changed dramatically about
25 million years ago they did just that
during this period tectonic events
across the Indian and Pacific Oceans
transformed the Open Sea creating many
shallow water grassy regions
scientists believe that this shift is
what caused seahorses to diverge from
their ancestor the pygmy pipe horse
eventually emerging as the upright
swimmer we know today
that's because swimming upright has two
main advantages in grassy environments
the first is increased maneuverability
swimming upright allows them to move
through the blades of grass easier than
if they swam horizontally
the second is camouflage in addition to
a color changing ability that many fish
and other sea animals possess a
seahorse's upright posture helps them
hide in their environment
vertical Blades of grass and coral can
more easily hide a vertical fish
so seahorses cling to them using their
prehensile tail and this hidden position
doesn't just provide them protection
from predators it provides them stealth
for hunting
in fact researchers have found that the
denser the vegetation the more
successful sea horses are at capturing
their prey
one study found that adult sea horses
had over an 80 percent success rate in
highly dense habitats compared to just
30 percent in habitats with low or no
vegetation
and for seahorses a high success rate in
hunting is particularly important
considering they're missing a key
component of the digestive system their
stomach
without a stomach food passes through
them rather quickly this means that they
have to eat all the time but luckily for
them they are among the most impressive
Ambush predators in the world
being bad at swimming makes it
impossible for seahorses to chase down
their prey instead hidden within the
seagrass or Coral they vary very slowly
get close to their unsuspecting Target
snap their head around and quickly suck
them up through their tube like snout
this technique is known as pivot feeding
and seahorses have perfected it they're
able to score a meal in record time it
happens so fast your eyes can barely
comprehend that anything has happened at
all
to rotate their head with such lightning
speed elastic energy is stored in the
large tendons of the apaxial muscle a
muscle associated with head rotation and
then quickly released
this rotation brings their mouth closer
to their prey
then with a widening of their snout a
suction force is created that pulls the
food into their mouths
and it happens astonishingly fast in
less than five milliseconds once they
begin to Pivot they're already enjoying
their meal making them one of the
fastest feeding vertebrate animals
but being highly skilled at pivot
feeding isn't enough seahorses first
have to get within Striking Distance of
their prey without being detected and
the typically calm Waters of their
habitat don't make that easy
any motion could send a ripple through
the water clueing their prey in to their
approach
one of their main food sources copepods
are especially sensitive to hydrodynamic
disturbances
they can respond in three to four
milliseconds and make a quick Escape at
a velocity of 300 meters per second
and for the pivot feeding technique to
work seahorses need to get within close
range within about one millimeter
luckily seahorses have another trick up
their sleeves their long snout
one group of researchers took a closer
look at how the dwarf seahorse sneaks up
on and captures its prey using
high-speed digital recordings they
measured the 3D motions of seahorses
copepods and the surrounding water
during an attack
they found that the seahorse's elongated
snout creates a quiet Zone where fluid
motion doesn't exceed 0.8 millimeters
per second compared to the 4.1
millimeters per second in the
surrounding area
this region is located right above the
end of the snout in the Striking Zone
allowing the seahorse to sneak up on
their prey undetected
in contrast the Striking zone of a
related fish without an elongated nose
the three spine stickleback had the
highest fluid motion compared to the
surrounding area
with this oddly shaped head the
unassuming seahorse is one of the most
remarkable Hunters of the ocean every
oddly shaped creature of the underwater
world may look absurd to our
land-dwelling sensibilities but every
strange creature is strange for a very
good reason the ocean is an immense and
hugely variable place with millions of
ecological niches and sometimes it's the
weirdest who survive sometimes it's hard
to imagine how Evolution would have
favored such a ridiculous animal how
small genetic changes can lead to
something so extreme
but by understanding The genome and
natural selection the crazy complexity
of the Web of Life Starts to all make
sense I've studied evolution in the
traditional sense for many years but
recently the world of genetics has burst
open thanks to the power of computing
problems that would have been impossible
to solve can now be done in minutes with
algorithms and machine learning it's a
hugely exciting area of study and one
that I've been diving into deep with the
computational biology course on
brilliant it's taught me how computers
have helped us reconstruct genomes and
build phylogenetic trees to look at
evolutionary relationships brilliant is
an amazing tool for learning stem
interactively all the learning is
Hands-On it has you writing code solving
equations and doing puzzles to learn
college level information with brilliant
you don't need a four-year degree to
understand calculus computer science or
neural networks this was all stuff I
thought I would never learn stuff that I
thought I had missed my chance with or
that was too difficult for me but I've
realized that that's not the case at all
I am astounded with how much I've
learned by doing just a little bit every
day brilliant has thousands of engaging
lessons with exclusive new content added
monthly and one of these new courses is
ours our team has worked closely with
brilliant to build a brand new course on
the physics of rocket launches a real
engineering course custom made with our
viewers in mind so head over to
brilliant and let us know what you think
of it and what other courses you'd like
to see on brilliant from our team to get
started for free visit brilliant.org
real science or click on the link in the
description and the first 200 people
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription
thanks for watching and if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now watch our most recent video
weighing in on whether monkeys are pure
evil or watch real engineering's latest
video about deep sea mining